what's going on guys
Star Wars The Force awakens it's hitting
blu-ray and DVD next week the journey to
get back to the force has been one long
and winding road and screen junkies
we've been there every step of the way
so join us as we take a look back at the
steps along that journey in the first
ever little screen junkies rewind so
climb into your at-at and travel with us
to a time before the force a woke awoken
to a time when the force was still
sleeping
before we get started I'd like to tell
you that this episode is brought to you
by audible to learn more check out the
link in the description below or stick
around to the end our first stop takes
us back to November 2012 when a young
fresh-faced Hal Rudnick announced the
news that sent shockwaves through the
galaxy hey guys did you hear that Disney
owns everything now Outback Steakhouse
beards and oh yeah Star Wars the
internet is abuzz with questions who's
gonna direct it is on solo coming back
will there be Wookiees will there be a
walks will Derby combination look walks
so it turns out there were no book walks
in the force awakens still kind of
bummed about that JJ I think you owe me
a walk walk journey with me to almost a
year later when I sat down with Michael
Bharati and Justin Donaldson to discuss
what it would take for the new
installment of Star Wars to be good
everybody who has been a part of the
original trilogy theoretically could be
back I don't know if that's a good idea
I want them to be the only people in the
movie really yes the last thing I want
to see is Mark Hamill in a lightsaber
battle present Tay okay I admit that was
pretty a gist of me but in my defense
Mark Hamill's most prominent live-action
role before Star Wars Force awakens was
as cock-knocker and Jay and Silent Bob
strike back so but that your pipe is
smoking you may remember that for months
one of the biggest mysteries surrounding
this movie was what is it going to be
called well we didn't sit around
twiddling our thumbs waiting for an
answer no
created the Star Wars title generate
which was basically a spinning wheel
with a bunch of Star Wars words on it
you know what we came up with some
fascinating results all right let's find
out the title of episode seven
absolutely hope attack there you have it
Episode seven attack of the hope mark if
you would give it we're gonna give it
two spins
Gungans Devon the Gungans Senate if you
thought we could not get worse than the
prequels get ready for Gungan Senate is
it too shameful to admit that there's a
part of me deep down inside that
desperately wants to see the Dungan
Senate in 2014
screen junkies debuted movie fights a
forum for personalities and fans to
passionately debate movies and go on
record with predictions that would end
up being horribly wrong here's what
happened when we asked what film would
make more money star wars force awakens
or Avengers age of Ultron what do we
think is gonna win the box office credit
scene is it gonna be Ultron is it gonna
be star wars episode 7 I'm actually
gonna go with Avengers how much cash
does Han Solo have with today's young
generation my 13 year old nephew doesn't
give a crap about Star Wars and he Marv
Marvel is his Star Wars Dan would like
to explain yourself I was really wrong
from there
we here at screen junkies engaged in
what movie fans do best
speculation seemingly endless hours of
beautiful speculation from what the
title of the movie means it is called
the force awakens
who has it who's it awakening in the
force awakens was it asleep this whole
time that crazy new lightsaber wasn't
like a full stream it feel like it was a
little jig like Genki yeah I like that
is it just the sets that get the cool
lightsabers
right what George Lucas be involved you
at least want to hear what George has to
say whether you use them or not as a
completely separate issue for every
charger and like midi-chlorians he had
here to lando calrissian until april
2015 we got our first sweet taste of
Star Wars Force awakens and we moved
from speculation to prediction let's
take a look at the predictions some of
which were right and some not right is
the Millennium Falcon that part of is it
is it sitting in that sand what about
the Darth Vader helmet we saw I think
that that is specifically in there for
the sake of the teaser it is a little
bit melted just like returning Jedi cuz
he was he lit his father on fire
I think someone kept it yeah and who's
the weirdo that kept it or the badass we
see this lightsaber and it looks like
Anakin Skywalker's original lightsaber
from the prequels it kind of bumps into
him he turns around and gives him a look
now my theory yeah he knows that he's
been captured and he's like what are you
doing here ken has a different theory I
think it's more of hey you're here
you're fighting with us now and I'm
proud of you carrie fisher's in the
trailer they still shacking up those two
would appear so yeah anyone is going to
bring Luke back into the fight against
the new empire it's gonna be his sister
Princess Leia
he's not gonna show up until the end he
is going to be there from nearly
beginning to end I are out there
interior I guess I have fond memories of
that era known as Star Wars jacket
speculation finally last December Star
Wars Episode seven hit theaters in the
fans awakened and they engaged in an
age-old bloodsport that sent tremors
throughout the galaxy anyone who doesn't
like it I'm gonna go on record as an
a-hole there was no point that I felt
the nostalgia was over-the-top or forced
III felt they were too cute by about
maybe 10 to 20 percent I know this is
the best Star Wars movie ever made to me
it's not even close the best movies are
not made by committee this Force awakens
movie was clearly made by committee
after seeing it four times which might
be my own problem I rank it higher than
Jedi as an initial entry it's even
stronger and braver and more
then a new hope thing with a lot of it
did it's a fun movie I'll give you that
I enjoyed it saw it twice I've seen
almost no conversation about what's good
about this movie it seems to be almost
exclusively what's bad even from people
that liked it I thought the characters
are really thin a really thin like I was
shocked they were like video game
characters yes you can do a bunch of
stuff but we couldn't whether you like
the movie you didn't like the movie
people online or pissed at you about
that oh you know it's hard to believe
there was a time when we didn't know who
Ray was or how cute bb-8 is or why
Harrison Ford was so happy to promote
this movie it's because he'd never have
to do it again hey so what'd you think
was that a fun trip down memory lane or
did it seem like we just wanted to make
an easy episode just using old clips let
us know in the comments below should we
do this for another movie Captain
America Civil War or fan for stick no
we're not gonna do it for a fan for
stick but let us know in the comments
below also tell us your thoughts about
that long winding road that led up to
Star Wars Force awakens thanks for
watching hit me up on Twitter I'm Hal
Rudnick bye bye thanks again to audible
for making this episode possible audible
is everything you love from Star Wars to
Doctor Who to Star Trek and right now
audible is offering our viewers a free
30-day trial membership just go to
www.sceeto.com the screen to start
listening now